So in the last lesson, we saw that UIKit contains many visual items like
buttons and labels.
Now, inside UIKit are several other classes that help us
manage these visual elements.
One of them is called UIVewController.
This class helps us manage a view,
especially its life-cycle events like viewDidLoad, viewWillAppear, etc.
You may recall that we created a class called ViewController,
which inherits from UIViewController.
Then we use something called UINavigationController.
This class helps us navigate hierarchical content in our apps,
which is just a fancy way of saying it allows us to move from one screen of
the app to another screen.
Now, there are a few links in the instructor notes that will give you a list of
all the classes that are inside UIKit and
the relationships between those classes.
This includes an image that lists out all the classes and
how they are connected to each other.
I recommend that you browse through them now.